how do you attract name talent to a
movie I think a lot of it is just being
genuine you know like at the end of the
day whether it's film or not film or
whatever position it's just being
authentic and genuine because people
could sense the BS you know if you're
just trying to sell them or whatever
um so I always come from a place of
authenticity you know and telling them
why I want to work with them you know
whether it's in an email or
social media or whatever the case is but
what I've done is that I've figured out
where a certain actor or actress is
going to be that I may want to work with
so maybe they have a film Premiere at a
festival or
let's say
um uh
I will attend you know like a screening
you know a private screening that's
happening uh like I'll track screenings
you know so for for example I'm a member
of bafta uh and uh now it's bafta I
think America so I can go to baf the
screenings in New York LA and the UK so
if there's a particular talent that I
want to work with a lot of times they'll
end up going you know to a q a uh at
bafta and um I've approached numerous
actors that way anywhere from like
Orlando Orlando Bloom to Mark Ruffalo to
individuals like that and it's not
necessarily easy to get in front of them
but
um I look for a window after the Q a
um usually I try to go actually as soon
as it ends because sometimes they just
run out
um and I'll just pull them to the side
um if they have a rep or don't have a
rep there if they have their rep there
it's a little bit more difficult because
their rep will try to shut it down
but if their rep is not there usually
their publicist is there you know if
their reps aren't there but I go right
to the point you know I talk about their
past movies what they've done why I like
them and that I want to work with them
and um can I contact them directly uh
and I want to say in terms of Mark
Ruffalo um I was at a screening for dark
Waters in New York
um and he just hung out he just hung out
the entire time afterwards which I was
really shocked and he talked to everyone
in super kind and I told him that at the
end I'm like I can't believe you talked
to everybody and stayed and
um and he asked me a little bit about
who I was and what I was making what I
was doing and
um and I pretty much answered those
questions and without even asking he had
offered me his email address which was
insane I mean did I end up getting him
for the project you know that I
mentioned to him no it didn't happen you
know but um but I believe it was
authentic and genuine like the
conversation which is why he gave me the
time of the day you know
um and entertained it um
so uh and the same thing happened with
Orlando Bloom I went to a screening of
Carnival circus in New York and he was
there and he was coming out one of my
favorite movies is Kingdom of Heaven
another Ridley Scott film told release
got the same thing I love kingdom of
heaven and I told Orlando Bloom how I
love that and
um and Troy and all the other things
that he's done and and he's like oh yeah
that's great man we could find
he's probably typical he hears oh I want
to work with you and he's like yeah we
should find something work on you know
just passing through I said actually I
have something
um and I just went right into my pitch
and he was like Wow taken back and he
flagged over his assistant assistant
came over and we exchanged info and we
started conversation did it manifest
into anything no you know probably you
know the rate we offered him was too low
and maybe he wasn't impressed with the
filmmaker
um and the the thing that was probably
logically true is because
um
um he probably had a lot of you didn't
have availability he was probably booked
out you know
um I ran into Frank Grillo one time in
uh in West Hollywood and uh I happened
to be wearing a purge t-shirt so I saw
him I flagged him down I'm like Frank
how you know and he's like wait a second
you know you're wearing the shirt and
it's just it all aligned you know like
right place right time and I told him
how I knew James and he loves James and
we're he's telling me about another
movie that he did with James and Naomi
Watts and we're having a conversation
and then I'm like dude I tried to you
know work with you multiple times I've
tried to go through your agency your rap
that you know the creative artist agency
and they can be very difficult and I you
know listed his agents and his manager I
have a very good memory and so he knew I
was serious and like did you ever read
the script he never heard of it like oh
you know that's not a surprise I've
heard this story many times how talent
doesn't get material
and um and then I talked about his
production uh partner you know he works
with Joe Carnahan a lot you know and I
mentioned that I'm very close with uh uh
his publicist and you know um and I was
invited to a screening of a film that he
had coming out and I couldn't get into
La for that reason whenever it happened
um so he's like dude you know just why
don't you just contact me directly going
forward that's what he said I'm like oh
that's a great idea I'd love that you
know and he gave me his number and his
email and uh and I just stayed in touch
I followed up with him uh followed up
with him about the project that you know
I wanted him to work on and ultimately
he just told me that he wasn't available
you know and um to keep him in mind for
whatever else you know to reach out
um and uh it just didn't work out you
know uh so sometimes it works sometimes
it doesn't you know in terms of this
thing but
um I have a very aggressive approach and
I want to get in front of people because
they'll see the passion I feel and that
this person is like 100 legit on board
um and that I appreciate the film
process and the study and
um I'm not just like a fan I'm not just
saying I want to work with them I have
legitimate reasons and I'm able to back
it up and I make sure that when I share
whatever information about working with
them
I kind of just Tee It Up This is the
project this is when we're looking to
shoot this is the budget this is we have
the money we don't have the money uh
these are the pieces this is why we want
you on it you know how can we make it
work straight to the point so they know
I'm serious I'm not hesitating you know
um and I'm doing it in a concise manner
um I don't necessarily rehearse it but
in the beginning probably I did I've
gotten to a point where I'm just
comfortable it's a conversation and like
these are how projects happen and come
together so
um so I've done that
um also done the social media thing
where
um maybe reaching out we I've done it
once on Instagram
where it has worked there was a foreign
project I was putting together and
it's a very famous uh I want to say
Italian actress I didn't necessarily do
it but I had someone on the team reach
out and she read the material and um
you know she was interested it it didn't
work out because we didn't get all the
money you know to make it happen but
um that happened you know one time
um other times one of the things that I
do is that I did a film with Mercedes
rule
um and it was a short uh back back way
back when and uh one of the actors had a
really good relationship with her had
worked with her before and we basically
just went through her directly we never
dealt with her agents or reps and she
came on board so one idea that I always
say is like you get one you get all
their friends you know so that's a
strategy that I use and they want to
work with their friends you know so
um that's one way
um just getting a list from them like
who do you know who do you have a
relationship with who would be you know
like who you've been trying to work with
um
sometimes it's going through the agent
directly I do really well in Europe the
agents are a little bit more I want to
say flexible so if the actor or actress
has rep in the U.S and in Europe
especially if it's European project I'm
going to go through their reps over
there I've been able to like somewhat
attach talent that way
um it doesn't always work especially if
the US agent is not like friendly then
they'll shut it down sometimes that
works and then obviously using a casting
director that's been one way a lot of
the times you know if I don't have the
bandwidth or the energy or I just can't
figure out how to get in front of a
certain actor or actors you know we'll
just use that and it's a lot of work to
honestly you know
um you know there was a you know there
was a project I really wanted to get
Jamie Foxx involved in and I think the
night before uh there was a screening
happening in La I found out on a Friday
night a friend of mine told me about the
screening and I was trying to figure out
how the hell the fly from New York to LA
to get there in time you know to get I
couldn't find a flight to match it and
the flights were very expensive and I
was like oh man I really want to make it
you know
um so it just didn't work out you know
um so there's times like that where it
just doesn't work and it's probably
it'll be very hard to get in front of
him you know I've done that with um
he just Alba one time where
um I was actually at his party at
Sundance and his producing partner was
going to introduce us but when he had
wrapped up he DJs a lot he was wrapping
up his DJ set his security detail just
surrounded him because there were a lot
of people there and I guess he didn't
want to talk to anyone and he just voted
so the producing partner couldn't
introduce me
um so I had gone down to Art basil in
Miami and I knew he was going to be
there at this club DJing and I went to
the club and I waited for him to come
and he came out of course but it's
really dark it's loud and there's a
million bodies in front of you and I
just couldn't get through I legit
couldn't get through and I was just like
so pissed I'm like I can't I can't
believe I did all this to get through in
front of him
can't even talk to him and even if I did
a part of me is like it probably
wouldn't work because he's DJing and
it's so loud and he's not gonna stop
DJing to talk to me so I thought out
like how it could work like some
sometimes it works out where there's a
moment where they're by themselves or
whatever and you get that moment to talk
to them and other times it's just
impossible because security around them
or you know it's a loud venue
but um I would say my success rate is
pretty high because again I'm very
polished and buttoned up when I approach
an actor or actress and it's not as a
fan you know I have an agenda I have
proof of whatever I'm talking about you
know I make sure it's in a place that it
has some type of element that's exciting
whether it's an exciting writer or
director or both or a production company
or producer or I have money I'm not
going to come with a bad script with
nothing you know because it just doesn't
make sense you know so
um just along the way I've just met a
lot of great talent just being at
festivals you know like just walking in
Santa Monica one day I'm walking and I
oh man it's like Craig Robinson and then
I walk over I'm like wait are you Crag
you look like Craig is like yeah like
dude you know I said like I'd love to
you know like work on something with you
and he's like oh cool we should find
something to work on and I'm like
pitching him and I'm like dude give me
your number then you know he's like okay
gives me his number and his email then
we started a friendship a relationship
so
um I just reached out to Craig you know
I brought in projects and
unfortunately uh it just didn't hit you
know like he wasn't interested in it or
wasn't what he wanted to make and do so
just you know and we just said hey we'll
find something one day eventually but I
have that open Lane where I don't have
to go through his wraps or whatever or
be blocked
um so I've done that quite a bit with a
few actors and developed relationships
with
um and it's out of the box most people
aren't thinking they might be
intimidated or they um don't know how
what to say and uh maybe in the
beginning I would have been really
nervous but I've practiced
so many times like doing Toastmasters
and
um Toastmasters is a not-for-profit
group that helps with public speaking so
I've practiced my public speaking so
many times in a group in front of one
person some people good one-on-one and
they could talk one-on-one and some
people are good at talking to a group
I've practiced both just to be able to
because I believe that it's my
responsibility to be the best producer I
can so that's investing in myself you
know this has doesn't do it film but
taking classes where I can be the best
me so I can show up the best way and
that's really helped me to be able to do
these things and figure things out
um
so that's one of the ways that I find
and attract Talent or work with talent
but I've done everything under the sun
as you can see to work with Talent do
you adjust your approach based on New
York La Europe like is there is there an
LA approach that would not work in New
York and vice versa
um the thing is that I try just to feed
into like how I would do it I don't look
at the fact that I'm in New York or LA
because what I've been told by my
colleagues in La is that it's
inappropriate don't do it you know like
you could be shamed for it or whatever
and I've seen it being in an LA party or
whatever there'll be like some cool
person you know and people just like
pretend that they're not there but they
know they're there and it's like it's
like weird you know what I mean oh it's
like it looks it belittles you if you
like go and talk to them and you know
like no like I'm just gonna go in it
doesn't matter and you know and I and I
use my personality that's where I feel
comfortable in myself you know whether
they say they don't want to talk to me
or not they could just say no you know
like I don't want to talk to you I'm not
interested I want to say most actors
that I've met and approached you know I
just come coming really direct like hey
this is my name this is what I do want
to work with you love your work what
you've done this is the project
how can we do this and they'll say maybe
you know contact their reps I'll deflect
um I did that with Eddie Redman I I ran
into him right after he uh when he was
nominated I think and um
he didn't want to give me his direct
info so he said if you really want to
contact me you don't want to deal with
my reps you know I don't want to deal
with my agent contact my manager you
know and my manager you know responds
don't worry about it you know and that's
what I did so
um it's their level of comfort if they
don't want to give me their email or
phone number
um then that's fine you know what's the
best way to contact you you know so
um yeah
does rejection
um challenge you
uh in the beginning I think rejection
was you know very challenging but the
thing is that people say no for so many
reasons and sometimes it's no because
they woke up on the wrong side of the
bed and sometimes it's just legitimately
they're not interested so
um because I've rejected you know
projects or not necessarily people but
things and you know it just doesn't
align or the timing's off or you know
um I was speaking with a colleague of
mine yesterday that won an Oscar last
year and he um was nominated for another
Oscar in another movie he's done two
really big movies and he has two other
really big movies coming out and you
know um and everyone's going after him
right now and he's like listen like I
want to do projects where I collaborate
with people I don't want to just do jobs
and um the thing is that
um I can't do everything and a lot of
times I turn down really big paychecks
or opportunities or you know getting
offered an overall deal and it doesn't
make sense but this is my process you
know
um and I want to spend time with my
family I want to do this I need to take
two months off after this movie comes
out the end of this year
um and just hearing that it's like okay
cool like he's rejecting you know really
big his agents he's rejecting you know
big money opportunities he's rejecting
you know A-list people on the level of
you know Spielberg and it wasn't
Spielberg but that level and you know
it's not because he's rejecting them
it's just that it just doesn't fit with
what he's doing right now and he wants
to be the best him when he does a
project so
when I go to someone and Pitch them and
they reject me you know I don't make up
a story I look it for what it is what it
is is that they said no and that was it
they're not rejecting rampus the
individual they're not rejecting even
the project they just maybe they just
don't have the capacity or maybe they're
dealing with you know a sick child or a
sick family member there's so many
things that could be going and I read
this book called The Four Agreements and
one of the rules in The Four Agreements
is don't take anything personal so I've
embodied that with my day-to-day just
not to take things personal Memphis do
you have a project for almost everyone's
if we saw a b or c walking down the
street somewhere in Hollywood Santa
Monica would you be like oh so and so I
love your work and you know their work
inside and out you know their IMDb
credits
um it's 50 50. like half the times I
have something that'll fit because I
fluctuate with multiple projects I have
a slate you know of different genres
um so I would say fifty percent of the
time I have something that would be
great for them to do the other fifty
percent of the time I don't you know but
um when I don't have something like if I
ran into Jennifer Aniston for example I
don't have anything that would be for
her per se but it would be good to have
that in the back pocket if I have a
project that makes sense so I'll give
you a real story of what happened
I was at Sundance Film Festival
uh this was 2018 and I was going to a
party that Christine volsung was
throwing from killer films really dear
friend
um uh and uh I was going in to the party
but at Sundance you have to be on a list
it's very strict and the group in front
of me couldn't get in because they
weren't on the list the group behind me
or the guy behind me um so the guy in
front of me couldn't get in and the
girls behind me couldn't because they
weren't on the list but the guy in front
of me we hit it off so well and I went
into this party and
it was for the film that they had done
with Dominic West and Keira Knightley
they were there
um I didn't approach them because they
were like in this area and there was a
lot of security and uh it probably just
didn't look right or good if I broke
that line so I didn't do that so I just
engaged with Christine and you know the
people at killer films and I uh went and
spoke with uh you know other individuals
that were there so I met a guy that was
a talent I think he was a talent agent
became talent manager or maybe he was a
talent manager you know he was a talent
manager you know and then I met with
another guy that's a financier you know
um they went later on to finance
parasite which was really cool
um and we just hit it off so well
um so I stayed in touch with these two
they both lived in La
um and then when I wrapped up at
Sundance I went to LA I usually spend
like a month in La afterwards just doing
all my follow-ups with people I've met
and then uh the guy that was in front of
me that couldn't get in I met with him
and he told me about what he was doing
he's Canadian he's between Canada and La
um and he told me that he would send me
some of the projects He was involved
with so he'd sent me one project in
particular that I read uh I found it
really interesting and
um I uh I was telling him just giving a
a report of you know who I've met in the
relationships because sometimes the the
access that I have can like fit so I
told him that I met this talent manager
in the party that he couldn't get in
that I got into and the talent manager
um they represent Billy Bob Thornton so
he's like oh my God I have that project
you read really would be great to direct
you know and what I was told was that
Billy was looking for stuff to direct
you know as well so
um I was able to set up the relationship
and
um and then they had the money in the
bank they were able to make an offer for
ability to direct the film so I had all
the pieces to basically put it together
and he said if I could make this happen
I'd come on as a capital P producer I'd
be involved
um and uh I went to the manager and I
told him exactly what happened and he
said send me the material I read it and
I sent him the offer as well so he knows
that there was actual money and it was a
significant offer
um and then
um he gave the script to Billy Bob
Thornton and
what ended up happening was that Billy
didn't connect with the material he said
he passed it wasn't for him but in a
perfect world you know Billy would have
said yes he would have directed the film
you know the financing came through this
guy that I met online and the script and
you know it all comes as one so with
that said when you act when you ask me
in terms of like Talent sometimes you
know it's like I'll get the right pieces
to put it together to activate it you
know so I always think about that I have
six thousand phone numbers in my phone I
don't always think of everything in all
the pieces but there's a way for me to
make it work if that makes sense you
know so
um yeah I mean I I would still approach
the talent and tell them XYZ and I'd
love to find something to work with them
on you know and it's really depends when
they're on that level of DiCaprio or
Jennifer Aniston and Vin Diesel it's
really hard you know to get in front of
the 101
um because they're always around
somebody
um and uh it's going to be very
difficult to get Leonardo DiCaprio's
like phone number you know
um but it's not impossible you know I've
seen him at can if I really wanted to
get in front of him there's a way but it
would be very difficult to navigate it
but I would still take the shot